Coffee on a Tuesday and blog 23 in an
art studio.
Oh,
sorry.
I was just checking the twitter APP on
my iphone.
Now.
Someone.
Someone tweeted me.
Actually that was like a minute ago.
Now I'm reading New York Times article
about the Syrian uprising.
A really interesting,
a really devastating to,
but I'm actually.
That was like a minute ago to now or,
or um,
uh,
no,
that actually,
that was 20 minutes ago.
I guess you can really get lost in the
temple.
If I was a kid,
eight to 18,
these last few minutes would consist
only of a fraction of the seven and a
half hours a day that I spend with
media.
Do I care?
Not really.
By which I mean of course that there was
a fat chance to them.
I'm going to stop doing seven and a half
hours.
That's from a study conducted by the
Kaiser Family Foundation in 2009 up
about an hour and a half from the same
study done in 2004.
So now in 2012,
I think it's safe to say that we're
probably pretty close to eight hours.
What's the day into nice even thirds,
right?
Eight hours of the day we sleep eight
hours of the day.
We consume media like rabbit hungry
wolves and eight hours of the day,
week,
what do we do for the other eight hours
of the day?
Yeah,
so
what's to be made of all this?
I don't want to criticize those who
spend a lot of time with media.
Clearly your relationship with media,
like everything else is your own thing,
your own a affair,
but I do think that there's something
missing from the Kaiser Family
Foundation report.
See,
today's media is social,
which means that it consists not only of
consumption but also of expression and
these two things are relentlessly
intertwine.
Whatever you consume has been expressed
by someone else and whatever you express
will be consumed by others.
There was a total awareness of this in
social media.
Facebook and twitter are not journals or
diaries.
Whatever you post on there is posted
with your complete understanding that
others will see it and not only see it,
but probably will comment on it and thus
express themselves for your own response
of consumption,
and so a facebook status like a novel or
a Vlog is a request for judgment.
Any cereal tweeter who tells you that he
or she doesn't care what other things
should be left at shared expression is
the definition of caring what others
think.
There's such a thing as expression for
its own sake,
but that's what these are for.
The point is that whatever medium of
shared expression you choose will be the
medium by which you are asking to be
judged.
If all we're getting from you in terms
of expression,
is curling up in bed with the salad and
a movie until the grammy's start to
finally relaxed.
Feel so nice gifts.
Crack was a little too wet for Whitney
Houston.
She did work in on a Saturday night,
man,
I'm to lose work,
homemade crab Rangoon,
or you have to participate relentlessly
in the manifestations of your own
blessings.
What?
Don't be surprised if you're treated
equally as simple equally as trey
equally as idiotic.
We should never forget or forgo the
understanding that expression from a
conversation to a feature film is always
difficult to do.
It well requires a measure of
composition of time and a willingness to
improve.
Despite frustrations.
Your social media personality is not
you.
It's a performance review and maybe for
yourself.
It's easy not to confuse that
difference,
but it's not so easy for all those who
see only this performance and who are
disposed in many ways to treat others as
stereotypical as they can and maybe
sometimes you get frustrated feeling
that others don't understand.
You don't see your respect,
what you want.
Maybe you feel like you're always coming
out of conversations or arguments with
your point poorly made well,
I'll let you in on a secret.
Those who can speak well to the point
and with lucidity practice these people
trip up like everyone else,
but less often.
More Times than not,
they make their point and come out of
even in normal conversation,
feeling like you have a better
understanding of what they want and who
they are.
Not everyone is or has to be an artist
that everyone has to write a novel or
make an album,
but there is something to be said for a
little bit of reserve when it comes to
expression.
That way you can preserve some of your
own mystery,
some of your own subtlety.
You can escape some unnecessary judgment
and you can recover the power of your
own voice.
Oh,
sorry.
Just getting a tweet.
What could she possibly be painting?
Cut.